he's uh not only a great player great
dunker great actor he was an uncle drew
he's aaron gordon the orlando magic
forward kind enough to join us
uh aaron good morning how far is your
house from the bubble
what's up dan patrick good morning good
morning thanks for having me on the show
my house is wow we actually looked it up
you know we went on use the iphone we
used the app
the navigation app i'm 12 minutes from
my house
how weird is it that you're in orlando
and you can't go home
being in the bubble
it's pretty weird i uh the worst part
about is i can't go home and see my dog
wait you couldn't bring the dog to uh
the bubble
i thought that would have been a great
mascot to have the rottweiler
you know named matt named magic you know
i thought he was just
i figured i'd just leave let him loose
on the campus and just have them run
around and intimidate the other players
but
i guess they didn't really want that but
what happened but you know people have
those comfort dogs when they go on a
plane
couldn't you have said to the
commissioner couldn't you petition to
say you know he's my comfort dog
oh he's definitely an emotional support
animal you know i got his papers and
everything
so you know how do you
bit one of the other players that would
have made me much more emotionally
stable
if uh what is the biggest adjustment so
far for you
um i guess it's just
being away from the family and you know
not
physically having your family members
and friends in the crowd cheering for
you
the uh the i mean the crowd it just
isn't there
you know so it's very quiet and in the
uh
in the gym when you're playing like you
can hear a pin drop when you're on the
free-throw line
but also i'm wondering about this aaron
i'm being serious that the language
that's going to be on display we're
going to hear everything i don't know if
it's going to be on a seven
second delay where tv can bleep out
something
are are you guys aware of this have been
told about
you know watch what you say during these
games
i think they're doing uh i'm not sure if
we're mic'd up or not
um i think it would be uh actually
hilarious if they
let you guys hear everything that
consists in the nba game and like almost
on all the trash talking i think that
would be it
but what would i hear that might
surprise me but what's the best
uh exchange you've heard since you've
been in the league that we would be
entertained by
oh man
you know who who's one of the best trash
talkers is uh draymond green
you know he does it night in the night
out
and we're playing uh this was back in
orlando so this was before the bubble
and um we were talking
and uh i think the refs called
a travel on me and i was like no i
didn't travel
you know that's that's not i just don't
do that you know what i mean that's just
not something i do
i've never traveled in my heart right
now i don't know what to do
draymond was like oh you just do
everything perfect time i was like yep
that's right that's damn right i do
everything perfect i'm nice out here
and he was like yeah you did everything
perfect but when and i was like
[Laughter]
i was like okay okay i see i see how
we're coming
i would like to see draymond green on a
t well this year on a team that wasn't
any good
and does he still talk trash when his
team isn't any good
uh we didn't play him we didn't play him
i definitely would have
he's a friend of mine you know so i
definitely would have given
you know some of that i would have
dished some of that back if we played
him
um i think he was out to the game that
we played though
who's the mvp this year in your opinion
and that's a good question it goes
between uh
lebron and giannis definitely um
i think i'm gonna go with lebron though
uh i think the bucks
are just a better overall team
you know i think obviously with uh
lakers having a d
danny green and a couple other pieces
they're really really good team but if
you take those two guys out i think the
bucks probably win more games what's it
like to guard lebron
man well uh it's it's a fun task
you know it's definitely challenging uh
his
just his natural feel for the game his
iq is just through the roof when it
comes to
in between those lines so you know what
makes him so challenging is his passing
ability
and people don't understand like he's
one of the best passers in the game
and um if you cut him off one way or cut
him off two ways he finds the open man
and hits him right in the shooting
pocket so
you know he didn't score a lot the last
time we played against him but he had
like 17 assists or something like that
is he a trash talker a little bit
a little bit brenda he does chirp a
little bit if you talk to him
um but uh you know i was
i was grown raised with the uh quote let
sleeping dogs lie that's
kind of like it's true as it comes with
lebron you know as long as you don't say
really much to him he won't say too much
to you
but i look at anthony davis and and i i
don't know if you can make this argument
i think lebron is the league mvp as far
as business goes like he's he's the draw
he's the face of the nba
i think the greek freak's going to win
comfortably and i also think he's going
to be defensive player of the year
but anthony davis might be more valuable
to the lakers because it feels like you
know he's
he's their scorer and their rebounder
and the guy who's blocking shots
can can you see that that you know a.d
might be more valuable to the lakers
than lebron is
uh i wouldn't say more valuable um
just for you know face value like what
you're talking about
and then just as far as leadership goes
um but ad is definitely is the spark of
that team
who's tougher to guard a.d or the greek
freak
man that's a tough one um the greek
creek is
incredibly difficult to guard just
because he's uh
he's so relentless on the court you know
he's one of those guys that if he misses
one shot or he misses two shots
misses three shots he's shooting that
fourth shot and he's really
always on attack milk so the greek freak
is uh janna's
really hard to guard um but you know
there's a lot of ball plays
a d is tough to guard too man there's no
knockout
i just haven't had uh the task of
guarding them as much
how do you feel about your chances in
the bubble
your team i feel really good
i feel really good about it uh we're a
couple of guys down still
um between markelle fultz and jonathan
isaac and alfred
arugamino hopefully we can get two of
those three guys back
uh get more lomba uh some more playing
time and get him in a better rhythm
um but you know i feel like because we
were everybody was off for so long we're
all starting
from the same kind of uh you know start
start point
so i feel really good about our chances
i think
we can possibly get up to seventh seed
and then get into the second round and
then who knows from there
did you actually dress up as aaron judge
for halloween
oh yeah that was a that was crucial man
that was very crucial i was getting
erin joe's comparison all the time
even in new york they would come up to
me and be like hey
uh i know you you play for the yankees
right yeah aaron josh i was like no
no that's that's a different area and
they're like oh and they they kind of
step back for a second and then they
like come back in they're like oh
oh oh oh aaron gordon it's like yeah
yeah okay wrong
right aaron you know wrong well you guys
are both the same size and you do
look a lot alike no i agree with you
i agree he's a cali kid too man so um
yeah maybe one day we can do like a
commercial or something together have
you met him
no not in person you know we've just had
brief exchanges over social media
oh yeah you guys got to get together he
looks like he weighs more than you do
i'm not 100 sure i think i might be a
couple
inches taller he might be a couple
pounds heavier well wait what are you
six
eight yeah about that well judge is what
six six six seven something left
six six six seven a big boy would be
playing
playing baseball i mean he could play
power forward in the nba if you wanted
to
i'm looking at the picture and if i
didn't know better
if if that was the yankees the yankee uh
uh
locker room i would swear that that's
aaron judge
absolutely absolutely if that was the
yeah if that was
really the yankees locker room and that
was really energetic the yankees would
be
a far worse baseball can you did you
play baseball
no i didn't it was it was a little too
um a little too slow for me yeah but
also weren't you a great
sprinter yeah so i did a track and field
um played ice hockey volleyball
um soccer football
cross country pretty much pretty much
the works
except for uh america's past time
yeah but i'm i'm looking back like when
you were young you were
you were like a junior olympian is that
is that about right
yeah so um i had uh i was going to the
junior olympics in oregon
so we were on the way i qualified um
to go in a chance for a gold medal
but we had a local basketball tournament
and i decided to go to the local
basketball tournament instead
and i guess that just kind of told me
you know
where my passion where my heart really
was where it resided
yeah is there a sequel to uncle drew in
the works
and i hope so i hope there's uh like
uncle casper or something like that you
know you may bring it right back around
her uncle drew too i'm not sure man i
know kyrie's working on a lot of
different projects right now and
especially with all of the uh
you know just kind of political strife
and social injustice going on in the
world
you know on one hand it would be nice to
have another
um comedy and family friend friendly
movie but
i think there's a lot of things that
need to be addressed in films and
documentaries
on the social justice side so um you
know
hopefully we can do it again um but you
know if not it's okay too
who was the best actor on set
and i think uh either kyrie or uh
chris webber preacher c webb was
definitely
he was definitely one of the best i
loved weber's hair
oh it was it was so good but you're
right kyrie
was a a great actor that role was really
well done
with uh with kyrie but i i we were
talking about this morning you know
the fact you were going to be on i said
c webb is a
sneaky great role by him he was great as
the the preacher
yeah we're definitely an agreement and
he locked into that
and also wasn't that on set where kyrie
found out that he was being traded
yeah it really was um
it was it was after a scene you know and
he was uh
he was really excited actually he was
running around
um bouncing off walls you know
he was fired up well it's good to talk
to you good luck there in the bubble
and uh thanks for joining us as always
hey thanks man i appreciate it all right
that's aaron gordon